Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Mark White, and my position is in the sales department.
As you can tell from the title of my presentation,...
...the topic I would like to speak about today...
...is methods to get customer feedback about products through informal communication opportunities.
First I'd like to outline my presentation...
...before I jump into the background of how feedback is usually obtained by our company...
...and why informal feedback is useful.
As you can see in the handout, there are three main points I'll talk about...
...regarding each informal communication opportunity.
Let me just write those three points on the whiteboard...
...because I'm going to be referring to them a lot in this presentation.
Then we can move on to the brief outline and introduction.